welcome i'm ph tanker i teach a theology
and ancient Mesopotamian history and
religion at harvard and today i would
like to share with you a very special
canadian tablet which belongs to the
collection of the Harvard Semitic museum
it is one of the most important
cuneiform tablets in our collection in
date roughly to 1700 BCE the reign of
the great Hammurabi of Babylon it is
written in the Akkadian language what
makes this tablet so unique it is a
manual of the divination police called
burro and Akkadian another term for his
respects and he was a specialist ritual
specialist who foretold future from the
appearance of sheeps intestines the
tablet contains 142 lines this is what
we call the front side of the obverse
okay so this is the beginning of the
tablet here I would like to point out
the describe is incredibly small and
tiny quite unusual in that way so we
have probably some like 60 lines over
the crown or the obverse and then the
tablet continues on the back of the
rivers of the tablet up to here the
manual tells the diviner what he may
find in the extra and you know how he
should analyze the extra the text begins
with ritual instructions for the diviner
which instructing how he should invite
the gods to the christmassy and the
center figure here is the Sun God and
how he may ask the gods to - - to obtain
a favor
answer to his require so he should offer
offerings because offerings say some
prayers and then he should sacrifice a
sheep having slaughtered the sheep
he then should ask the Sun God and other
gods for for for a positive answer and
they are supposed to inscribe the answer
in the entrance of the sacrificial sheet